anarchism is you know voluntary
cooperation in exchange is the basis of
any healthy society and the problems
only come through public crime
governments or private crime criminals
so if that's the case we're we're right
now what country today is running on
that system so anarchism isn't a
location anarchism is a relationship so
anytime you have two people or two
organizations or two entities or more
where they have no semblance of
authority higher than them that is an
anarchist relationship and let me give
you a good example we don't have a world
government right so if an American I
apologize for this and if an American
kills the Canadian in Mexico who has
jurisdiction no one but they still have
some mechanism in place between the
three of them because every country is
in a state of anarchism toward every
other country so anarchism again isn't
like a place it's a relationship between
different entities
foreign
[Music]